[Music]
Noah Baumbach smeared story is less
about marriage than it is about divorce
depicting the souring of what started as
an amicable split between an actress and
her theater directing husband like 69%
of divorces in the United States the
wife initiated the separation we learned
that she felt oppressed in her marriage
believing that her career in ambitions
were consumed by those of her husband
but the marriage was fairly egalitarian
by modern sensibilities with both
husband and wife working and sharing
domestic responsibilities this gets it
what is one of the most important social
issues shown in the film though likely
not bomb backs in tension studies show
that women on the whole seem to have
lower satisfaction rates with their
marriages than men even after decades of
men doing more housework and more
childcare and women spending more time
in their careers
many women seem no happier than a
half-century ago and maybe even less so
maybe it's that society has created
unrealistic expectations for women
marriage not only means finding a soul
mate and a helpful father and a
breadwinner
it is also an exercise in
self-fulfillment did you think the movie
marriage story was an accurate depiction
of marriage today let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI